I get irritated very fast small things
make me mad this is not a joke this is
an example because I want you to
understand what I'm saying I don't like
it when people eat and sweat at the same
time I don't like
I don't like like somebody's eating
while they eat they're like
I'll punch you on the face if
I'm there I swear to God I'll punch you
in the face slow down
anybody gonna take that food from you
slow down
tell you what else I don't like you're
not gonna like it but I'm gonna tell you
anyway
I recently realized that I don't have
any patience for unattractive people
there I said it that's how I feel
I know when you first hear it it's a
blow it's a blow at first
I said you stay with me okay stay with
me until the end
I feel like they're very needy
unattractive people are very needy they
always want something
excuse me excuse me
excuse me you know what I can no I don't
no no no no
I treat them like cats get your
ass out of here
get out of here you better get
oh
it's too much
it's too much let me tell you
where the joke came from so you don't
think I'm a dick okay
I was at the bank right I get done at
the bank I'm in my car I'm about to pull
out the parking lot you got to stop at
the little parking Booth right you got
to give the guy your ticket I go to get
a guy my ticket he Slide the glass back
sticks his head out very unattractive
man whatever
he sees me when he saw me he lost it he
got excited he said
make that ugly ass face right in my
face
kill the heart of my bank you got to be
kidding me
he said I'm gonna let you out here until
you tell me why you chose us why us why
do you bank with us why'd you choose us
as your financial institution
I couldn't believe what the I heard
I don't have time for this
that's the button I mean the out of
here I don't have time he did it again
hey let you out here to you tell me why
us why'd you choose us Why Us why'd you
choose us kept saying us I told you I
don't have any patience I lost
it I snapped I said stop saying us
you don't got to do that goddamn
Bank this parking lot ain't got to
do with that bank hit the button let me
the up out of here
this is when I got mad he looked me Dave
and I he said I got all day Kevin Hart
all day
I realize he's not playing he's not
gonna let me out I gotta answer this
question okay fine you wanna
know why I chose this Bank your customer
service loan rates free checking there
you go that's why that's why I chose
y'all this is what pissed me off he goes
that's all you have to say with your
little ugly ass I said what'd you just
say
get your ugly ass on my line
[Applause]
pissed I'm not ugly you ugly
pissed
I stop at Chipotle two blocks up
it's a long line of Chipotle now I'm
even more irritated I'm only in this
long-ass line because of that
unattractive ass conversation
while I'm standing in the line the woman
behind me goes oh my God day's such a
nice day it's so beautiful outside I'm
about to snap I'm a loser
I'm a snack I'm gonna turn
around I'm gonna let this goddamn woman
have it I turn around I see her this is
by far one of the most attractive women
I've ever seen my life she was
gorgeous immediately instantly
I had time I had time I said I
said you know what it is a nice day it's
so nice outside
I turned into a weatherman I
said what we need is rain we ain't had
no rain in the middle
she said I wasn't even talking to you
turn her back on me
what the
oh no no that is not acceptable excuse
me excuse me excuse me excuse me she
turned around what
ah
I just want
I just want to know what made you choose
Chipotle as your place for lunch today
I was an unattractive person in that
conversation
guy flipped it on me that fast let me
tell you some people no matter how good
you think you look I promise you that
you don't look that good
I promise you something will happen in
life to show you that you don't look
that good my wife gave me in
reality check
we was in the bed watching TV commercial
came on with a little monster from Lord
of the Rings smeagle I think that's his
name smeagle he was doing this
right here you know a little monster
that's what he did he was doing this
my wife said oh my God babe you be
doing that I said what did you
just say to me
did you just say you be doing that
in the morning
[Music]
I said to my goddamn face